[Music]
today we're reviewing this the 6950 XT
and this one is massive it's about 7 cm
deep or something like 2.8 in or so so
this thing is one of the largest video
cards that is currently being sold at
least as of today it's up there with
some of the 3090 TI and 390s and the
reason for that is because it is both
power hungry and as a result pretty hot
so this is the refresh of the 6900 XT
it's in the same architecture it's still
on 7 nanometer it's the same die and die
size but it's a little bit faster and
the memory especially has gotten a
change today we're going to be
benchmarking this at $1,200 isll $1,250
with this model uh versus some of the
other cards in the market before that
this video is sponsored by linode linode
is a Linux server hosting provider that
GN has used for nearly a decade now for
its own servers alongside dedicated
website hosting lenoe makes it easy to
cut out thirdparty VPN services to build
your own VPN that you fully control
easily configured via the interface
lenot also has hundreds of guides for
custom servers including game server
apps like rust Minecraft csgo and guides
to host your own video calling servers
to eliminate third parties lenot is a
great way to Take Back Control of
software and your hosting and Gamers
Nexus viewers get a $100 credit for 60
days on new accounts at lin.com Gamers
Nexus or click the link below okay so
this particular one is the sapphire
Nitro plus pure and we're going to be
doing a tear down of this separately so
if you want more details on this
specific card and how it's constructed
definitely we'd recommend you checking
that out uh ultimately this is a 6950 XT
GPU AMD of course supplies the GPU and
the memory the memory is 18 GB per
second up from 16 on the previous 6000
series cards that's the refresh here
clocks get boosted a little bit as well
there's some other changes will go over
to but for the card itself this
particular one is a three fan design
it's running three axial fans and it has
three vbio switch positions two of them
are physical V bioses on the board and
then one of them is controlled through
software this is something Sapphire does
the most immediate thing to point out is
that this card has three pcie power
connectors so it's got two eight pins
and one six pin that should be a pretty
good indicator as to the power
consumption of the card itself now for
pricing so there's three cards that AMD
is pushing out today officially we are
only reviewing this one right now they
are the 6950 XT msrps 1100 $ for that
this model again is 1250 there's the
6750 XT that's at $550 and then the 6650
XT which is a $400 card now if some of
you haven't checked in a while it's
worth looking at gpus that are in stock
near you now because we just checked
before this review we were able to find
3080s in stock on new and Amazon for
example the pricing for the cheapest one
we found there sold and shipped by new
It's A step above the thirdparty
marketplace at least least uh that was
$900 the cheapest one we could find at
the time of writing and filming this so
they're available they're close to where
they launched which isn't bad certainly
a lot lower than it was over the last
year or so the 6900 XT we found in stock
for about $1,000 that is in fact the
price that it launched at and the 6800
XT we found in stock for $800 to $900
little on the high side uh at the $900
Mark but much better than before the
reason for mentioning this is because
now finally the argument is going back
on the consumer side of things so
instead of a card launching and US kind
of going the value is not good but what
are you going to do buy something else
fools now we can say actually you can
buy something else so finally it's it's
looking good for consumers again at
least a little bit initially it's
starting to get there uh so as you watch
the review and the benchmarks just know
that there are actually other cards you
can buy at least at the time we checked
when filming let's go through some specs
here so 6950 XT versus the 6900 XT they
are are basically the same they're both
520 mm squ die sizes it's the same die
they are both 7 NM process node uh both
adcu or compute units and therefore both
5120 stream processors they both have 80
rate tracing accelerators they both have
128 RS the cache is the same capacity at
128 megabytes the memory is the same
capacity at 16 GB so then the actual
differences come down to memory
bandwidth for example there are two
memory bandwidth numbers there's eff of
an actual the one we're going to talk
about as actual actual raw memory
bandwidth on the 6950 XT 576 GB per
second versus the 6900 XT was lower than
that at 512 GB per second that's the
difference of 18 versus 16 GB per second
memory now AMD also made changes with
the infinity cache speed from what they
were telling us and that helps with the
effective bandwidth so that's where
you'll see some of the gains made in
this GPU that might not otherwise be
expected since it's the same CU count
and SP count additionally of course
frequencies are different on this uh for
base and boost frequencies so that's the
card we're looking at let's get started
we'll look at the frequency thermals and
power numbers first power's high and
then we'll go from there we'll start
with a wide range of power consumption
so tested at the PCI cables and the pcie
slot combined not testing system power
the 6950 XT pulled 377 Watts went on the
stock vbios that puts it at 77 Watts
higher than the original 6900 XT or
about a 26% increase of power
consumption the RTX 390 ftw3 pulled
about 385 Watts just for reference with
the 390 TI pulling 500 watts under
normal conditions the 6950 XT with its
ocv bios ran at 411 Watts without any
other changes allowing 9% to overhead
for additional boosting overclocking on
either V bios pushed it to about 57
Watts that's a 35% increase over the
stock test and they both cap out at
about the same place the over clock 390
TI ftw3 is the only card that ran higher
power consumption than these results at
522 Watts we're definitely in Nvidia
fery territory or AMD Hawaii territory
with gpus now and the solution seems to
be Mega heat sinks that are three or
four slots wide not something they tried
quite as much or as confidently back in
the day but with s and Crossfire
basically dead now they've got the room
to do it thermal start out sort of rough
the average GB temperature was okay at
about 76° C but the hot spot temperature
jumps to about 95 that's for an
expensive large addin board partner card
TJ Maxx on these cards or the thermal
Junction Max is about 110° C so it's
technically within spec but adding a
higher ambient temperature poorly cooled
cases higher effective ambient it'll
make it a closer call for these big
cards uh or they'll have to run at much
higher fan RPM not to mention that this
is just the stock V bios anyway as for
how the fan responds to that it's
plotted on the right Axis hysteresis is
odd on the V bios programming for this
one as is a overall fan Behavior it
ramps hard to 1500 RPM on immediate load
holds for about a minute and then it
dies the fan Falls to about 1100 to 1200
RPM at this point allowing the large
Spike that we're seeing in thermals
that's with the stock V bio switch
frequency testing for the 6950 XT puts
it at about 2450 MHz during the same 3D
Mark workload as before the the
frequency mostly sustains with a slight
reduction throughout the test from heat
buildup the secondary V bios was almost
identical to the stock V bios overall
Sapphire should definitely be running a
more aggressive fan curve on this but
they're trying not to make the thing too
loud Total War 3i kingdoms is our severe
stress test we set Graphics to ultra
which allows a wider detection of
performance scaling at lower resolutions
starting at 4K the 6950 XT ran at 50 FPS
average which has it near the 3080 TI
and 5% ahead of the overclocked and
undervolted 6900 XT or 10% ahead of the
stock 6900 XT the 390 TI leads by 20%
but it's about 100% more money so
definitely not a lead to boast about
compared to more normal cards for people
who don't laugh like
this the 6950 XT is about 5% ahead of
the RTX 380 or 14% of the RX 6800 XT and
these are far cheaper if you can find
them and on that point too the market
has been improving so if you haven't
looked in a while you should take a look
at 1440p we still have room to see
scaling the 6950 XT ran at 106 FPS
average with lows proportionate to that
average this has it above the 380 TI but
only by about 2.6% so that's a technical
lead meaning it shows up in testing but
it's not a meaningful lead you're never
going to notice that the 390 non TI
leads by another technical but
irrelevant lead with the 390 TI leading
by a more noteworthy 10% the 390 TI
overclock shows that we're still within
CPU performance and bound by the GPU
which is good for reviewing these let's
look at this another way the RTX 380
achieves 89% of the 6950 xt's
performance and that's at 85% of its
power consumption it's a pretty close
1:1 ratio there the RX 6800 XT meanwhile
holds about 88% of the 6950 xt's
performance and that's at about 78% of
its power consumption so these high end
cards not surprisingly are less
efficient in terms of performance per w
at 1080p we still have room to see GPU
scaling which is great because for AMD
this is a benefit amd's current rdna
architecture runs disproportionately
well at lower resolutions while nvidia's
Amper runs disproportionately well at
higher resolutions we typically see AMD
and Nvidia trade at 1080P and at 4K the
6950 XT holds 161 FPS average here now
pushing it to a tie with a 3090 TI and
sorry 3090 tie in lows and average FPS
alike the 6950 XT is about 10% ahead of
the 6900 XT once again at 4K and high
settings shadow of the Tomb Raider ran
at 112 FPS average on the 6950 XT
placing it ahead of the original 6900 XT
by 14% the RTX 390 Thai ftw3 and the RTX
390 non-ti on ocv bios flank the 6950 XT
the 390 TI ftw3 technically leads at
6.2% ahead in average FPS with lows
proportionally ahead given that the 6950
XT Nitro is $1,250 or so and the 390 TI
ftw3 is
$2,200 overall we'd say the 6950 XD in a
vacuum only between these two is better
value than the 390 TI ftw3 here both
however are bad value when compared to
an RTX 380 an RX 6800 XT or even a 380
TI which we weren't that fond of for
Value to begin with it's normal that Hal
products have the worst value of course
since they're targeting a different kind
of buyer but there is a cut off that we
think exits being acceptable at 1440p
we're CPU bound and can't see any
meaningful difference it's a good thing
we had the total war results previously
though because that did show a
difference the 6950 XT and the 390 TI
are about the same here so we'll skip
1080p for Tomb Raider since it'll just
be bound anyway Red Dead Redemption 2
comes in both direct X12 and Vulcan API
so we tested both the Vulcan results are
very interesting we have a little more
limited data here because we don't test
it as often but at 1080p Vulcan still
shows scaling in Red Dead 2 by removing
most of the bottlenecking from the CPU
the 6950 XT runs at 175 FPS average with
lows pacing behind there are no frame
time pacing issues here the lead over
the 6900 XT is 3.6% with the lead over
the RTX 390 about 11% you can see that
Nvidia cards are all limited on about
150 to 157 FPS average for the wall as
they're all bouncing off of a driver
limitation at 1080p on the CPU not just
GPU limitations that is however still a
part of the GPU product you buy so it's
still a relevant difference the AMD gpus
are able to circumvent this and run less
limited still showing scale we can't see
the differences between the Nvidia gpus
really at the top end since they're all
restricted so you can ignore the
dragging performance of some of these
cards as opposed to some technically
lower end models at 1440p the 6950 XT
leads the chart with a 3.7% gain on the
390 TI ftw3 the lead over the 6900 XT is
about 10% aligning with previous results
and contributing to the same average
overall uplift at 4K we see the ampor
architectural Advantage coming into play
the RX 6950 XT Is Now bested by The 380
TI the 3090 and 3090 TI leading only the
380 and down this is consistent with
previous research we've done showing an
overall Advantage friend video at 4K and
for AMD at 1080P or 1440 next is dx12
we'll keep the short at 4K and dx12 the
6950 XT ran at about 96 FPS average that
has the 390 TI About 11% ahead of the
6950 XT with the 6950 about equal with
the 3090 including in lows and about 11%
ahead of the 3080 compared to the 6900
XT the lead is closer to 15% at 1440p
the 6950 XT and 390 TI OC are both
pushing the limits of The Benchmark and
are functionally tied the lead over the
original 6900 XT is about 7% here with
the lead over the 6800 XT at 7.5% and
then it's 19% over the 3080 Horizon zero
dawn has good scaling as well at 4K the
6950 XT ran at 91 FPS average that puts
it about tied with the RTX 380 TI
leading the 6900xt by a relatively
meaningless 3.2% the 390 pulls ahead by
9% here with the 3090 TI jaunting 14%
ahead the 6950 XT isn't meaningfully
different in performance than say a 3080
or 6900 XT but the cost is definitely
meaningfully higher at 1440 the 6950 XT
pulls further ahead as compared to its
4K performance and these Advantage is
shining through here at this lower
resolution and the 6900xd shows this as
well where it pulls ahead of a 380 TI in
fact the 6800 XT also pulls ahead of its
competing at 380 so overall amd's
performance has improved relative to
Nvidia when looking at 1440 but again
that's old news by now it's still being
reiterated by the 6950x though at 1080p
the 6950 XT leads the chart as Nvidia
gets bound up at around 170 FPS average
that's a lot of money to pay for 1080p
gaming though we'd expect most users
would be on higher resolution monitors
here Rainbow Six Siege at 4K the 6950 XT
ran at 196 FPS average planting between
the 3080 and the 380 TI this has it 16%
ahead of the 6900 XT and it allows the
390 a lead of about 6% so not that
exciting overall at 1440p the 6950 XT
ends up at at 8% ahead of the RTX 390
that we recently retested just below the
390 TI and more meaningfully leading the
380 TI and the 6800 XT than in some
previous games it's scaling better at
1440p so that's it for the benchmarks
for the 6950 XT just strictly speaking
to what Sapphire has built here the card
itself looks very nice we don't normally
talk too much about looks but they have
actually done a really good job with the
uh color matching typically when you do
different colors across different
materials like metal and plastic it's
tough to get things to match and look
right you'll normally have one that's a
little bit off they've done well there
the construction feels pretty good we'll
see how it is actually in the tear down
The Thermals certainly are on the higher
side how much of that is on AMD meaning
how much of it is what else what options
do you really have other than liquid uh
versus on Sapphire will also be revealed
in the tear down they don't have a ton
of plastic blocking the exhaust it's a
little bit but it's nothing like the
thick series of XFX cards that was the
actual name and and uh overall the
construction of the Sapphire card is
good that does not change the fact that
the GPU from AMD is exceptionally
expensive it is not as much of a step up
in price as say a 3090 the 3090 you the
place where those get defensible pretty
much only is not in gaming really
obviously same for the ti but rather in
certain production workloads where you
just need a ton of vram but you don't
want to go Quadro for one of the many
reasons you wouldn't go Quadro we use
309s in one of our editing machines
because they work the best for what we
do Andrew does a lot with Unreal Engine
and blender and uses the vram in that
and we find that it works a little bit
better with Premiere than some of the
quadro cards we've worked with uh on the
driver level that is so that's sort of
the defense for a 3090 for gaming our
recommendation is still don't buy it
it's way too much extra money for not
that much extra performance for the vast
majority of people and the same is true
for the 6950 XT this thing is so massive
every time every time pick it up it's
like that's heavier than I thought it
would be uh the 6900 XT we said the same
thing we're like the 6800 XT far better
value you get the vast majority
overwhelming majority of the performance
like close to 90% for a much lower price
and the same remains true here so uh the
conclusion then is you should check out
GPU prices for your region we're seeing
they're starting to come back into where
they should be closer to it and that
means you have options that means that
you don't have to just refresh the page
when a card launches and hope to get one
because it's the only thing you can get
and that starts to take away some of the
argument for this particular card and
the 390 TI and others that Nvidia has
launched recently as well so if you can
get it close to $800 to $900 a 3080 a
6800 XT they get you about 90% sometimes
plus of the performance of this thing
and they are cheaper by upwards of$ 400
plus dollars depending on which cards
which models you're looking at $400 you
will will absolutely notice that money
you can keep the money you can put it
into other parts of the build you can
improve the CPU the memory the cooling
any number of things but putting it
towards GPU unless you are doing
specific production workloads with say
like a 3090 where you need the memory
capacity except for in that scenario
putting it towards a GPU you're probably
not going to really notice the frame
rate change realistically speaking some
FPS snobs maybe you can convince
yourself you can rationalize that you'll
see it uh ultra competitive types maybe
but for the most part we just think that
it's it's a bit extra money for a lot of
extra money for not that much
performance and that's sort of the end
of the review here it's like a lot of
the others except with one really
defining point this time that we haven't
had recently which is that there are
other cards in stock at least when we
wrote this hopefully that's still true
when the video goes up um and so we feel
a little more optimistic now it's been I
really kind of like downtrod in
reviewing gpus over the last year or so
because we knew the market and it's hard
to keep saying the value is bad the
value is bad value is bad cuz what are
you going to do but anyway it's looking
better hopefully it sustains even if
they go out of stock it it from reports
we've been seeing around the web it
looks like it has improved overall
that's it for this one thanks for
watching as always check back for the
tear down the card itself uh sapphires
credit here is actually a really nicely
designed card from everything we've seen
so far and we're excited to take it
apart so subscribe for that go to store.
Camas access.net grab one of our tear on
toolkits mouse pads or Mouse mats mod
mats other things like that and help us
out as well or you can go to patreon.com
Gamers Nexus to get some extra videos
subscribe for more we'll see you all
next time